foreign
we are now gonna head straight to one of
the fundamental points of the debate the
question of whether more sex is always a
good thing and to kick us off on this
I'm going to ask Iran to help us out to
answer that one is more sex always a
good thing Iran
no obviously not certainly not in an
individual level I mean uh it depends
what motivates the sex it depends on
whom the sex is with uh it depends on on
on the context in which one is alive
just
um uh uh you know a lot of um
a lot of sex with uh with strangers just
for their pure physical physicality of
it a lot of sex without intimacy a lot
of sex uh just for the sake of having it
or as Susanna said a lot of sex because
it's socially required or demanded or
expected of you all of those uh are
clearly uh clearly negatives uh when one
is though on a societal basis if uh you
know you can make those kind of
conclusions independent of everything
else going on in the world I don't know
that we can say much about just the
numbers regarding sex what is the
optimal level of sex for society uh for
large groups I I think this is something
that every individual has to choose but
I do think that when you see a strong
movement particularly among the Young
it's an indication of something it's an
indication of of of of of some issues
that that are that are happening and the
fact that that uh Susanna said that
people are not even looking to date or
not looking uh is a little while Sim I
mean one of the great again one of the
great Pleasures in life is relationships
and if if it's so horrible to go out
there and and try to establish
relationships then maybe there's some
issues in our culture that need to be
thought about and need to be addressed
what are your thoughts on that one we
are is more sex always a good thing
um I'm I'm absolutely not a believer in
absolutes
um however you know I I think it's up to
each individual person's preference I
think if someone wants to be totally
asexual and live as a monk in the
mountains and that is what makes them
happy they should go and do that
um I personally uh sorry you're on I
love a good Anonymous romp in the hey I
gotta say there's something particularly
fun and exciting about that and um I
don't think it has to be uh necessarily
a lack of intimacy if it's someone you
don't know there can be something
um especially beautiful about that kind
of connection where it's very fleeting
but
um
very intense
um but yeah I think I think people
should really try to get in tune with
what they want and what makes them happy
and I think people
um
some people aren't starting to do more
of that I actually think you know people
gender and exploring their sexuality is
so healthy because
[Music]
um
it really lets you
um just get in touch with with what you
want
um I do think that uh there can be a lot
of online discourse though that can get
really toxic
um where people
um will shame someone for having
different preferences than them and
um there's this uh sense of
righteousness from people who have
different preferences like you should
only have sex within a marriage or like
sex is evil and bad and you should only
do it to make babies or
um you should have like sex all the time
and be a total [ __ ] because that's the
that's the best way to be I think
um is
um and and so what about do you have any
concerns about the younger generation
who might be having less sex I mean do
you have any sense of why that might be
the case did you think at this point
that having less sex is just a question
of personal preference or do you have
any concerns that it might be linked to
um kind of underlying shifts in I mean
Iran kind of touched on it didn't you
the idea that maybe like our wider
culture whether it's social media or
other elements might be Shifting the way
that we even think about sex and who we
want to engage in sex with
I think social media is such a big
factor that uh you know I
um
you know I have younger siblings to
um
you know they will uh
there's just so so much pressure
especially with platforms like Snapchat
um where you can screenshot everything
um I think you know it used to be you
could phone up a pretty girl and say Hey
you know do you want to go on a date
with me
um and if she says no there's not
necessarily A record of that or if you
ask her out in person like she can go
and tell her friends and maybe talk [ __ ]
about you
um but you don't hear that either but
now it's like you send her a text
message you're like hey do you want to
get dinner I think you're cute and she
screenshots it and sends it to her group
chat with all of her friends and she's
like oh my God like how weird and creepy
I hate this guy he's so annoying and
then one of them sends you a screenshot
of the group chat and then all of a
sudden you see all these people talking
[ __ ] about you and you feel terrible and
you're like okay I can never ask another
girl out again and I think it leads to
this sort of neuroticism about like I
think it's talking [ __ ] about people is
fine I think asking people out even if
you're not totally sure if they like you
is fine but having all of that shoved in
your face is just not healthy
um I don't think everyone needs to know
everything that everyone is saying about
them
thank you um Susanna can I turn to you
for this uh initial question and what's
your take on the more sex issue is more
sex always a good thing do you think
that the uh the reduction we're seeing
in the figures is is a sign of a wider
problem or is it just a shift in
personal tastes
I think that um as you said research
um shows generally that it's not about
how much sex people are having but why
they're having the sex so if couples are
told to have more sex if they're doing
it because they're told to
um that doesn't lead to Greater
happiness if somebody is wanting more
sex and they're not getting it that
could lead to a decrease in happiness if
they are
um having sex
reluctantly then that could be a
negative thing so it really depends
um I think that having
what you were saying about the younger
generation is interesting because I
remember in high school like going home
and chatting with people on AOL Instant
Messenger like people I went to school
with and I feel like um you know that
has probably increased just that people
are connecting digitally more than
physically I've worked with people as a
coach who um felt awkward in sexual and
romantic interactions and felt more
comfortable online so that could be a
part of it that people maybe
um are less practiced in how to have
in-person interactions especially like
during the pandemic
um and maybe people are less comfortable
with that and that could be a negative
uh reason why people may be having less
sex so let's talk a little bit about the
underlying reasons for this I mean we've
touched on social media briefly uh I I
know that porn is often brought into
this conversation it was one of the
factors so although we know that
attitudes to sex are changing what do
what does the channel attribute those
changes to
um you know some people would say that
actually porn dating apps are supposed
to encourage people to have more sex are
they actually having the opposite effect
are they ruining sex for people when
they should or in or a mentor or sold to
us is is actually improving it Liara do
you want to kick us off on that one
um I would be happy to yeah I think
um I think it's really unfortunate that
people use porn as a source of sex
education
um as a performer
um it's pure fantasy you know we're
shooting these scenes and
um it's you know often two hours for a
short five minute clip
um so there's a lot that's cut out that
you don't see
um I think this country really needs
proper sex education and not just about
the pure mechanics of it
um but about pleasure
um because that's not something that
people should be getting from porn
period
um
I do think that other people from
diverse viewpoints making more important
would be great too so much of it is you
know kind of the same stuff and I get
you know it's what certain people are
into but
um I think there could stand to be more
diversity in porn to continue watching
this video click the link in the top
left or in the description below or
visit iai.tv for more debates and talks
from the world's leading thinkers on
today's biggest ideas
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Art
and ideas at IAI TV